nevada ranks ninth in the country when
it comes to suicide deaths and if you or
someone you love is suffering or
battling suicide
ideation there is help for you bob
vadavik from intermountain health care
joins us to talk about this more
september is suicide prevention month
and and intermountain health care is
very involved with us that's right
suicide prevention month is the month of
september and we are very much aware of
the depression and issues that are out
there with people and we want to make
sure that they're being
addressed so that they don't think about
hurting themselves or killing themselves
it is the second leading cause as it
turns out nationwide when it comes to
deaths among
children between the ages of 10 and 24
young people
yeah so young people are very prone to
unfortunately killing themselves because
they don't know often who to turn to and
who to talk to you know there's tons of
people out there that can really help
them their counselors their teachers
their friends it's really just a matter
of asking the question of them are they
okay yeah and how do you know
what signs can anyone look for either in
a loved one a friend whoever it may be
the biggest thing is watching for
somebody to be withdrawn you know
they're normally active they're normally
helping you they're normally interacting
well you want to see and they they pull
back all of a sudden and they're less
active they're not talking to you that's
usually a pretty good sign that there's
something that's going on you want to
address it and ask them if they're okay
yeah and and there is help for people
who need it and i think that's the
message certainly the intermountain
health care is trying to deliver this
month that's right there's always
somebody that you can go to whether it
be your primary care provider whether it
be a behavioral health provider whether
it be a friend again or a teacher or
just a confidant you can always reach
out and we always try and ask our
patients if they're doing okay just that
one question are you okay really can
open the door to the discussion and did
you find uh our
studies showing that this is a bigger
problem after the pandemic maybe as a
result of the quarantine you know it was
an issue during the quarantine during
the pandemic it still remains an issue
we haven't seen a lot in change as
changes go as far as the rates of
suicide
it's an ongoing problem there are
increasing issues right now financially
for people due to issues
and so there is a little more depression
out there
but i think
again it's just very highly prevalent to
begin with yeah yeah and as you said
communication is the key and just
opening the door for a conversation with
whoever it may be
bob vadovic from intermountain
healthcare really appreciate you being
here we do want to share some numbers
with you that are very important we
talked about the access and the tools
that people can have if you'd like more
information in general go to
intermountainhealthcare.org
forward slash nevada there you're going
to find things like now there's a 988
number that's right that people can call
all right bob thanks so much for joining
us las vegas now we'll be right back